[Music]
preparations are underway for today's
running of the kentucky
derby postponed from the first weekend
in may but the stands in churchill downs
won't be filling up because of the
pandemic
across the state in lexington there's
another story race track
keenland was founded in 1936 and this
fall will host
its second breeders cup it's also making
history with a coming leadership
change everyone around
this community and the equine community
at large has a keeneland story
it's a very special place to a lot of
people shannon arvin is the
president-elect of
keeneland racecourse a track that isn't
as well known as churchill downs
but holds its own in the horse racing
world one of my favorite stories of
keeneland would be
when we hosted the breeders cup in 2015.
an american pharaoh came around the
stretch
and won when you've got the triple crown
winner the first one since 1978 and
affirmed and that was so exciting to be
here and be a part of that
with his triple crown title and that
breeders cup win
american pharaoh became the sport's
first grand slam
champion
[Applause]
each year keenland hosts several
high-stakes races
giving away purses in the millions it
also serves as the most prominent
thoroughbred auction house in the world
with gross sales of more than 627
million dollars
in 2019. what happens at the sale people
do get in bidding wars and it's
fascinating 1 million 50 anyone else 1
million i have
right here 1 million dollars thank you
ralph the winner
the way people bet it's not like an art
auction it's not a very slow
you put your number up and the
auctioneer takes note it's fast the
auctioneer is talking fast crying fast
and the bid spotters know so well the
participants that sometimes this is a
bed
i mean i i don't go in the sales ring
because
i don't want to scratch my nose and be
mistaken for
bidding on a four million dollar horse
arvin is a practicing attorney
and has served as corporate counsel to
the race course for more than a decade
next year she becomes keenlyn's first
woman president
and continues her family's personal
connection to the institution
my grandfather was the first general
manager of the racetrack in 1935 and was
here until 1971
and my dad was counsel to keeneland from
the time he began
as a lawyer and then ended up as trustee
despite all the
the family ties this wasn't just handed
to you
absolutely not this is years of really
hard work
i hope it can be a symbol to other women
in the industry and to my little girls
who are nine and ten that
with a lot of hard work and perseverance
that can pay off and you really can
achieve what you're hoping to achieve
what she's looking to achieve
now is a broader base during this
pandemic
even without fans in the stands instead
of its traditional spring meet
keeneland held a five-day summer meet in
july
fans wagered 63 million dollars
wagering on u.s horse races topped one
billion dollars in july
that's a nearly 17 percent increase over
wagering
last year this time last year we had 150
hours
of national tv exposure for our sport
and this year so far we've had 600 hours
so as other major sports have not had as
many opportunities to play
we've had an opportunity to to push
forward which has been really important
also important the safety of the
thoroughbreds
shut them down last year there was
national
outcry after nearly two dozen horse
deaths in the span of three months
at santa anita park racetrack you
spearheaded
safety initiatives for the industry but
last year there was a lot of talk
about horse fatalities and nine horses
died at keeneland
you know there should be talk about
horse fatalities it's a serious concern
we take it very seriously we are
not sparing any expense to have all the
data
all the experts everyone available
to make sure that this sport is as safe
as it possibly can be and we
we're not perfect but we are committed
to doing that and to getting better
where did you need to get better
we need better pre-race examinations i
think
that's one of the aspects we've recently
hired an equine safety director as have
a number of other tracks across the
country
to be sure that we are in touch with our
thoroughbreds and we know the athletes
so that we can prevent an injury before
it happens
in november the racing season for the
world's greatest thoroughbreds
ends at this finish line and all eyes
will be on
keeneland you're hosting your second
breeders cup this year
in november how is that one going to
look
different than the one you had earlier
i think everything is different in 2020
right i think that's what we've realized
we will not have as many fans
and so we're just getting creative about
how we can reach people
and help them see the excitement of our
sport you know one of the greatest
things about being at the races is the
roar of the crowd
[Applause]
we had a race meet here in july and we
had 600 was the most people that we had
on any day because of our limitations
normally we'd have 42 000 and while that
was fairly surreal
and i definitely miss the roar of the
crowd it's that thunder of the horse's
hooves that you hear when they're
rounding the turn
for the finish line and you you still
hear that loud and clear
not many fans in the stands but they
found a way to make covet work
white a woman